Jamie you're Irish so you're in the
circulation area of the Sunday Times did
you know about Marie Colvin before you
started work on this fellow I did I just
first start by saying there's a first
Q&A I've done without rose and mouth or
director so you're brave man if I'm
really feeling very exposed yeah I did I
was aware of Marie's work she spoke to
you in a way that was very sort of
palatable I think um you know and you
see that in the way we depict her in the
film and the way she was and trying to
tell the human story and wasn't overly
concerned with what type of bullets were
causing the harm or what type of
explosions was it was a human cost and I
think if you're if you're a lot of
people only receive their news that way
it's once a week you were for the Sunday
Times and if you're only receiving like
that you want the very palatable version
of it's something that you can you know
understand and I think she was amazing
at that um even from quite young age I
remember being able to read her her
column so she had quite a big impact and
everyone in the UK really and beyond how
did the script come to you it came to me
quite late I think there was another
actor who was attached to it at one
point
he's a friend of mine and I was actually
filming a movie with him in Budapest at
the time that it came to me and I didn't
say I'm going to him because I knew I
didn't really know you never in know
what the situation is like that and I
knew Matt Hyneman our directors
documentary work which is incredible and
I was a huge fan of us and rose and I
have known each other for a very long
time but 15 years probably but as
friends and never had the opportunity to
work with her and there certainly was
she already attached
she was already touched yes she was
certain friends in the industry you
liked the idea of never working with
them because you have this fear that
they're going to be
not friends yeah well no just like that
you know a different version of
themselves when they work or something
so but roses of others people I always
thought I would enjoy working with and
um that package alone and just the you
couldn't read that script and not be
compelled to try to add something to it
and be involved in it so on I was
probably the final sort of piece of the
puzzle and then I had to do I'm friends
with Stanley Tucci so I had to do some
convincing to him - yeah oh you brought
him on coming listen I'm not gonna take
sole responsibility but um you know it's
Stanley's incredible actor and wasn't
the biggest of parts and but we really
wanted him so um I did my little bit
yeah and then you must have had to spend
time with Paul Conroy to get inside his
head yeah um
whereas Rawls obviously had you so clear
I mean I think she's incredible in this
film so care how much research she did
and how much sort of you know all her
research was based on video footage and
audio footage of Murray she spoke too
well couldn't get hold of her with my
met Marie's family and they were in the
Hamptons Film Festival a couple of weeks
ago and had their support that was an
incredible thing particularly for roles
I think but she had you know all
Murray's articles and everything that
she could get a hold of but I was he was
obviously never gonna get the real thing
but I was so fortunate I had Paul Conroy
I'm playing in the movie with us for the
entire the entirety of the shoot is that
a good thing it's a good thing not on
day one there was a good thing ain't day
1 of film set so nerve-racking anyway in
everyone's just so apprehensive and
excited and a city unique energy in the
first day and I didn't feel that I
wanted I had a pole at the monitors of a
set of Kansans I actually by this stage
you know we you know
been in touch a lot before filming his
schedule was more and say in the mind so
we actually didn't get to meet in person
just over the phone until the flight
over to a man working no he hadn't been
in the front line anywhere since Marie
died and since he sustained quite a
horrific injury his leg meat especially
after a few drinks he'll show you he's
got a he's got a massive hole and his in
his leg from from that incident and he
just basically had wasn't fit enough and
actually when we were filming in Jordan
he had this idea that he would then use
the fact we were so where we were
geographically to then go to Yemen and
get back in the front line to Yemen yeah
he wanted I know that's amazing these
people they want to go to these places
and tell the truth I mean it's so
commendable but um and that was his plan
but actually it was a very tough shoot
and it was you know we're 16 17 hour
days brutal so physically tough
emotionally yeah totally and so by the
end he wasn't fit enough I don't think
he'll make it a frontline again to be
honest he's um you know I swear I've
been with him all all this week in
London I literally flew in from London a
couple of hours ago and he's his Latino
his leg isn't quite what it you know was
so um he wants to continue telling the
story and you know he's got documentary
write about their time in Homs and
Murray staff and his escape from Homs
and he's still trying to spread the
message as best he can with some shoots
the emotional intensity gets drained or
relieved a little you know at the end of
the day did it sustained here I read
that you were in tears sometimes on on
set I've never um oh yeah I wasn't alone
in that it was a very emotional
cathartic experience for for all of a
sudden mostly because Hyneman our
director you know he spent weeks
interviewing all these real
Syrian and Iraqi refugees who are
displaced from those places and then
have ended up in Jordan in a man where
we shot so a lot of that stuff you see
you know in the in the like in the
widows basement in Homs and when Miraz
is interviewing those women and asking
them why they got to that point in their
saying what their real stories they're
not actors we didn't that wasn't planned
that is that is real they're real tears
that the woman who's saying that her
husband went to get groceries didn't
come back that's real so it was just you
can imagine what that's like to
experience and in their scenario with
the the mass graves in Iraq there a lot
of all those women were real Iraqi
immigrants who had been displaced from
Iraq and at one point they just started
wailing and doing this tribal sort of a
chance and throwing the dust on
themselves and that wasn't in the script
you know and then so suddenly we Bob
Richardson our teepees I'm sure most of
you know him he's won three Academy
Awards he was sort of in their face with
a camera and and you know it was that
sort of lying between you know is this
we want to capture this but as this sort
of this is are we exploiting these
people but every single one of these
people and this is why I got so real and
emotional times they would thank us for
trying to help in any way to tell their
story of the cost to civilians in these
war-torn places and that message was
just always very strong throughout you
know sometimes you make movies that are
strictly you know entertainment and
they're just meant to be escapism for
people for a couple of hours and
sometimes you do movies a carry a little
bit more weight to them and feel like
they're a little bit more important and
especially at the timing of this and
I'm anything that can shed light and I
mean look at Siri I mean that stout that
comes off the end horrendous over half a
million civilians since Murray was
killed
I've been killed in Syria and that's
people get desensitized to it I think
they get you know people could become
bored of it I think sometimes and it's
happening very far away from them it
doesn't concern passion fatigue totally
totally and sometimes it takes an image
that's were so fascinating you know
playing a photojournalist because
sometimes the day it can take that like
in a very arresting image like a boy
washed up on a beach you know like
happened last year for everyone to stop
and take notice so you know make a movie
that I think it's sort of a homage to
strife of these people and to journalism
really and what these amazing men and
women are willing to sacrifice literally
everything to tell us real truth please
thank Jamie Dornan